Chris Pratt wasn't always the risk
action star he is today
every year it gets harder and harder to
remember that his big break was playing
chubby but lovable Andy Dwyer on NBC's
Parks and Recreation Andy is our
official water fountain tester let's
give the sucker a test-drive how did you
slim down and muscle up to become
star-lord
here's a look behind the scenes of Chris
Pratt's insane workouts workout
rollercoaster as impressive as the
transformation was playing star-lord
wasn't the first time Pratt modified his
body for a role his bulbous weight as
Andy was a deliberate choice and he lost
a lot of it to develop a believable
baseball players physique for Moneyball
then he busts up even more to play a
tier 1 operator for zero dark thirty and
immediately after that he gained 60
pounds of pure gut to play opposite
Vince Vaughn in 2013 delivery men this
is you as the seal and then this is you
very shortly after Chris Pratt sold
vulture in 2012 close I just like to
gain weight and lose weight it's a
roller coaster I just want to do this I
want to touch God end quote
after that he started cutting down again
for Marvel's and now that he's in
star-lord shape it looks like he intends
to say there cold turkey anyone who
drinks knows that one of the lousy aside
effects of alcohol is the hit to your
waistline from all the empty calories
Plus hangovers
never been this far hurry did
unsurprisingly part of Pratt's weight
loss routine involves cutting alcohol
out of his diet which he did until the
first guardians of the galaxy was
complete he told Jay Leno quote I didn't
drink for seven or eight months which
was really not that difficult for me I'm
not like a huge alcoholic or anything
but I always prided myself on being in a
pretty good mood and then I stopped
drinking alcohol for eight months and I
realized from time to time I got grumpy
and close considering where it got him
it was probably worth the sacrifice good
eats
he may make it look effortless but
Pratt's body transformations haven't
always been smooth sailing while
preparing for his role as a SEAL Team
six member in zero dark thirty
that tried to brute-force his way
through a ripped physique while starving
himself while it worked in the short
term it definitely wasn't good for him
he told people in 2014 well I was doing
500 push-up the day working out at the
gym running five miles a day but with no
food and I tore my body apart I felt
terrible afterwards had to get shoulder
surgery and I wore myself down doing
that because I didn't have the proper
coaching and quote worse after all that
effort the weight just came right back
it wasn't until he started eating
properly and following a plan he could
sustain that he found a sweet but no
more yo-yo dieting for this guy all of
that is fruits and vegetables for weeks
now hmm oh my god insane workouts
dropping 60 pounds in six months and
keeping it off is no walk in the park
it takes everyday focus and
determination or as flat-footed three or
four hours a day of just consistent
ass-kicking hard work but he wasn't on
his own Marvel producers hand-picked a
personal trainer for Pratt selfie gave
her a former Navy SEAL who's made a
specialty out of getting actors into
shape as Gabe reduce crime Sue's
training philosophy quote it's less
about the workout and more about what
you bring to the workouts your will your
desire your discipline if it was easy
everyone would be in shape and close so
what kinds of workouts was he doing well
all of them heavy lift swimming mountain
biking cardio rowing calisthenics four
to six workouts a week on top of that
Pratt worked in some p90x and CrossFit
because why not it's enough to make your
body hurt just thinking about it oh my
god are you okay oh okay
from star Laura to Ironman speaking of
because why not in 2015 Pratt competed
in his first unmanned 70.3 a grueling
70.3 miles triathlon that saw Pratt swim
1.2 miles by 56 miles and run 13.1 miles
for a total of just over seven hours of
pain though fine-tuning his physique was
surely a part of the reason he took the
challenge his main motivation was to
support fellow participant Mike day over
hired Navy SEAL who was one severely
wounded in combat after the race Pratt
told Ironman Mike day story is just so
incredible I figured if a guy who has
been shot 27 times to toughness race out
I had no excuse eyes on the prize
anybody who's ever tried to diet or
stick to a workout plan knows it's an
easy train to fall from a couple of skip
days a cheat meal or two and before you
know it you're right back to riding
scooters to the bathroom but Pratt had a
pretty powerful incentive to show up for
his workout have a deadline that's like
if you don't give bad that you Michael
Aaron is here of course that doesn't
come close to conveying how seriously
Pratt took the exercise according to his
trainer Duffy gave er Chris's
athleticism is amazing he is incredibly
disciplined and his work ethic is
phenomenal he isn't the client who have
to push he's the type of client you have
to pull down and quote intense and
focused Pratt came into his training
knowing exactly what he wanted to be to
entertain film goers as the best
star-lord he could possibly be sorry I
didn't know how this machine thanks for
watching click the loop or icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to